яке якщо сукня з неспокійним середній
україну очисної до пасти стан 23
дні ми побачили багата порушені режиму
прибутку не зовні так само як тричі
цьому кредиту прикладу ми нарощували до
10 тисяч випадків у порушення режиму
тисячі рахунок і женя ситуацію можна
описати як передматчевої дружини
і причина польова в тому ще завищується
різак з дітьми на лінії розмежування
від же ваш до обранців алві 200 днів до
зараз знаходяться там факт ще сторони
конфлікту підходять був ще один огрядний
з причиняючи на кружляли ct ще ми
бачимо що дня дружина white ти станеш на
100 тис її на тій vps треба
гримлять мінську біля води мало збудують і
стабілізації у регіоні там мирному ви
вирішенню конфлікту че змогли мінську і
роки пофарбують і гуманітарну ситуацію в
середні україни химера incandessence
underground and east у неї край цієї
слід солдата мінської прямо відомо
мінське становище то кожухова прищепити
гуманітарний аспект
адже напиши все в моїй же двоособистій
конфлікту страждаючи самі цивільно
населення регіонів
паперових мінська заснула на робоча
група як позики ці самих cyma спектр
з пасторі ж на місії обидва стінами
дисплея та закріплення режиму тисячі
видно ви це критично важливий для нас
ціла інфраструктура а бути забезпечені
людям зубів бакіїв доступ до води газу
то електро пускача не
у батька і він малий ще владні може
заробити ваш монітор нового місії
ще розрізати і конфлікт усі травня ніби
зроблено щоб вирішити і його мірним повіям
тепер доступний відразу
мінську 100 платформі та платформу та знайти
чоловіка буде спочатку з рішення і дуже
важливо ще покладено німецьких ось і треба
Чи ви до нас у нас ще по кракові
втягувалася у стисканні на великі заходи
мацає baci не доглянуту обаму струнам та
схеми та емісії обидва та з'їдали Петро та
мотивацією процес або прогрес закласти
адже вікторин ти ж хто взяв на себе за
пов'язаний
постригати озави до неї механізмів
включаючи з нормандії форматом закласти
засмоктуванні політичного піску для того
щоб становище у вас було в тіло нам
жити один пункт інтервал від when the
ground